taiwan walker going to get the start
today taiwan this will be his fifth
start on the year overall
one and two record era just over four
seven watch 17 strikeouts in the 20
innings that he has worth
talk about steady how about justin
turner team best 12-game hitting streak
3-2 pitch
that's playable j.p crawford takes
charge
25 games into the season now bellinger's
average at 175
in the bottom five in the national
league taiwan looks in ready here's the
old two on the way fastball swing
and a miss for strike three down goes
bellinger a nice little threat building
here see if they can cash in with austin
nola coming up
nola one and two two and he's going to
get it
dylan moore's got plus speed he's going
to score easily seeger
waltz is in the third boston nola with a
long rbi
single with two outs the mariners get a
run here in the bottom of the first and
lead the dodgers one to nothing
on a clutch to a base hit from austin
nola the dodgers are down one bit of it
it'll be max bunsen to hit here in the
second against taiwan
walker that ball is crushed down the
line to right
inside the pole and gone an absolute
bullet of a home run from muncie to tie
it at one
anybody just put somebody's eye out
somebody's cardboard eye is gone the
dodgers have tied it at one well
muncie's average is down but six home
runs that's 12 rbis so he's been
somewhat productive
and getting some runs across and crew
including scoring some runs
you see some stress released in that
smile and that laugh
first home run for the dodgers since
monday it's noteworthy because yesterday
was only the fifth time this year
they've gone without one
jack peterson bases empty one out
another 2-2
peterson hits a line drive to deep
center field lewis turns there it goes
two solo shots here in the second and
the dodgers go from down one to
up one just like that this one was hit a
little
lower than max muncie's but probably
just as hard
and jock going to straight away center
field and stayed in the box and knew he
got
it that was an impressive read
on the strike of the ball tying and go
ahead runs are aboard
for jp struck him out and him a weak
wave second time jp is struck out first
time swing
santana comes in here worth remembering
that the bullpen when called upon to
have more than four innings of work in a
game
they've got an 8-0 record and a 1-0-5
era puts it in play that's a fair ball
turn a quick release one hop
and a play made over first by muncie and
that'll do it for the mariners they
leave two
one away here in the third cody
ballinger who struck out on three
pitches his first time in his own for
his last 13.
gets one lifts it in the air right
center field back towards the wall did
he get enough he did
got that fastball and drove it out of
here third home run of the night for the
dodgers and they lead
3-1 and with cody struggling he's going
to attack him with his best pitch and he
does the fastball and cody plants it in
the right center
gap over the fence well done the 1-1
swinging it's chopped hard third base
side turner has it foul ground now
taking it throwing onto first base and
it's not in time kyle lewis
is safe lewis will lead it first the 3-2
there he goes again the pitch is high
for ball four
the seeger walking in each of his first
two played appearances
well the man who's driven in the lone
run so far tonight for the mariners
comes to the plate now at austin nola no
bat here with seeger at first lewis at
second
swing and this is crushed mariners are
taking the lead
austin nola going way up into edgars
what a blast by nola his third
it's a three-run bomb and the mariners
have taken
a 4-3 lead you knew that right away
well the mariners were looking for a
clutch base hit they've had a bunch of
base runners early in the ball game and
here it is a breaking ball out over the
plate he weighed in on it
and absolutely crushed it the mariners
have a 4-3 lead and have the bases
loaded in the bottom of the third
dylan flora might have to have a cup of
coffee down there to get ready this
early
stretch and the next offer on the way to
jp swinging a line shot into center
field coming up is bellinger
reaching out and making the catch a
throwback to second diving back safely
at second is lopes
tagging and scoring from 30 shed long
and the mariners lead the dodgers five
to three
he has a great catch by bellinger really
could have been big trouble
yeah excellent jump by cody bellinger
max muncie coming up he's homered and
struck out tonight
kicks and deals 2-1 and muncie looks at
strike two
he's last at that max struck out on a
splitter down there
slightly below the strike zone
dave roberts and mark rippenger
dave roberts has been thrown out of the
game
[Applause]
first time this season roberts has been
ejected
now muncie swings and missing and he's
muttering to himself and he just got
thrown out
and now he throws his bat away and he's
getting into the grill of mark riperter
i feel like we should we should talk you
and i should both talk so we can cover
this up
um he's going to head back and out
here's bob garren to continue this
bob garrett will now be managing the
team with dave roberts thrown out that's
two up two down a couple of ground ball
out
that's well tagged deep left center
field
there it goes home run dylan moore 6-3
mariner lead second home run tonight hit
by the mariners for dillon it's on the
number five rbi number 10
on a two-hit knight stop calling it
sneaky pop he just has
pop i mean that's a line drive
we've seen him hit some long home runs
and this right here that pitch is down
he just golfs it
justin turner coming up turner is over
three turner's got a 12-game hitting
streak on the line
turner hits it hard base hit left center
field
that's headed for the plate lewis will
throw into second rbi
single for justin turner who has
extended his hitting streak to 13 games
seattle sits the dodgers four down in
the county here
the tying run at first base and one out
in the ninth inning
ruiz facing taylor williams who's ready
for the 1-2 1-2 to ruiz swing
and a miss for strike three and there's
two outs so now it's up to mookie betts
outside and the bases are loaded not
going down without a fight
a single and two walks in the inning and
corey seeger comes up
and the one-two on the way swing and a
missed right thread it's over
holy smokes the mariners won it six to
four over the dodgers tonight